let's take your base case of kind of we
end up somewhere around two percent uh
and then they kind of chill out a little
bit uh bitcoin today is trading
somewhere around thirty two thousand
five hundred dollars thirty three
thousand dollars and i use bitcoin as a
proxy for uh the crypto market overall
um when you think about that base case
how do you balance in your head uh macro
impact on crypto prices with what i'll
call more of the like micro market
structure of crypto and so using bitcoin
as the example we know realized price is
somewhere 24 25 000 we know that you
know 60 65 of bitcoin hasn't moved in a
year but we also know that the fed is
you know basically trying to nuke uh
asset prices and so like when you're
evaluating what could happen and it's
all probabilistic but like how much
emphasis do you put on macro and fed
activity versus you know bitcoin or
crypto people are crazy they're holding
these assets there is no price at which
they'll sell and like there's some
safety there like how do you balance
those
yeah um
we definitely look at both in our
investment process
and we look at the i say the
crypto
micro market structure from a pretty
quantitative perspective
and then we have a more kind of
qualitative
overlay
that incorporates both kind of crypto
qualitative fundamental
you know news flow type of stuff and
also macro
and
macro is
major league in the driver's seat right
now you know i think the first chart you
put up about the you know how tightly
bitcoin's correlated to the nasdaq
proves that point
i don't see a reason why
over
the immediate term
that bitcoin would or crypto broadly
would be able to
decouple from macro um
you know it's all one trade is it that's
as locked in now as it ever has been
um i do think that when bitcoin's 50 off
of its recent high like it is right now
i do think you get into a situation
where
you know
the supply demand imbalance in terms of
the people the market participants that
are willing to sell bitcoin
more than 50 off of the top
relative to the market participants that
are willing to
dollar cost average
buying bitcoin
50 plus percent off of the top
that that imbalance does start to swing
you know much more heavily in favor of
the buyers and we're we're very clearly
in that zone right now
um
we're we're coming up on
a spot
that's pretty important where we're a
couple thousand dollars below current
prices the uh late july 2021 lows
uh the bitcoin held if if we were to
lose that level which would happen with
a backdrop of uh
you know even more stress in traditional
markets than we're seeing right now some
of those stress points that i was just
talking about a second ago
um
you know i think it could get pretty
gappy to the downside if we lose that
that 2930k level and you could see a lot
of bitcoin spot bitcoin change hands
down there in the kind of kind of
mid-20s range for bitcoin and and that's
usually the type of capitulatory price
action that marks cyclical bottoms
and
you know i think there's there's a
decent chance we could see that that in
you know coming up uh but those would be
you know generational buying
opportunities that's like you know
you're buying for your kids kids at 24
000 bitcoin and and and so
one of the things that makes this setup
different than prior setups
is that the cat is out of the bag in
terms of
what asset
asset class you want to own
when the fed eventually
slows down on tightening or goes on
pause
you know and then eventually sort of
goes back to a looser monetary policy
that's very different than the like 1819
bear market
when
the vast majority of of institutional
capital wasn't involved in this at all
and didn't have any idea how to think
about this asset class i i think that
makes for for just a very different
backdrop just the the cat's out of the
bag like when the fed goes on pause
there's nothing on planet earth that's
going to move faster off of the bottom
than crypto i'm highly convicted of that
i think a lot of smart money is highly
convicted of that and and
this this tightening phase that the fed
is in
everybody knows that this is a pit stop
until you go on pause and then
eventually cut rates again and so all of
that combines into like a pretty
interesting situation where
yeah you know it's it's you know stocks
are nuking right now traditional is
nuking right now
uh crypto's nuking right now but if
you're not a forced seller uh
this is a terrible time to be selling
crypto to be selling bitcoin and if you
got cash on the sidelines you know
you're setting up for like a an
incredible buying opportunity so it's
fascinating to kind of hear you talk
through this not not not financial
advice of course not financial advice
nothing on this show's financial advice
entertainment purposes only